RUSSIA IS SUFFERING TROOP LOSSES
AND HAS BEEN UBLE TO TAKE
UKRAINE'S CAPITAL CITY OF KYIV
AS OF YET.
RUSSIA IS EXPANDING THEIR
ATTACKS.
RETIRED GENERAL DAVID PETRAEUS
IS HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE LATEST
ON THE GROUND.
GENERAL, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
LET'S START WITH THIS MAP OF
UKRAINE.
RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THE RUSSIANS
ARE WORKING ON FOUR MAJOR
FRONTS.
THERE'S KYIV, THERE'S KHARKIV,
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY THE DONBAS
REGION, THE SEPARATIST REGIONS,
AND, OF COURSE, CRIMEA.
IT DOES SEEM AS THOUGH RIGHT NOW
WE'RE HEARING IT'S SOMETHING OF
A STALEMATE.
WHAT IS GOING WRONG POUR THE
RUSSIANS RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, AN AWFUL LOT ACTUALLY
I.'S A STALEMATE.
BUT IT'S A BLOODY STALEMATE.
THIS IS NOT A CEASE-FIRE.
IT'S A BATTLE OF ATTRITION.
ON THE BATTLEFIELD LOTS OF
DAMAGE ON BOTH SIDES, LOTS OF
DESTRUCTION, ESPECIALLY FROM THE
RUSSIANS.
A BATTLE OF ATTRITION IN THE
SENSE OF THE WILL IN KYIV AND
THE COUNTRY AND THEN BETWEEN
THAT AND MOSCOW AND ESPECIALLY
THE KREMLIN AS THEIR ECONOMY,
THEIR FINANCIAL SYSTEM AND ALL
THE REST OF THAT IS JUST
COLLAPSING.
WHAT YOU SEE UP HERE IS THE MAIN
EFFORT.
>> HERE IS KYIV.
RIGHT NOW THEY SEEM TO HAVE
BEEN -- HERE IS KYIV RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET IN
THERE.
>> YOU'VE REALLY SEEN NO BIG
CHANGE TO THESE LINES FOR ABOUT
TWO WEEKS.
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN COUNTER
ATTACKING, WERE VERY LOCAL
COUNTERATTACKS.
HERE THE RUSSIANS ARE DIGGING
HOLES FOR THEIR TANKS BECAUSE
THEY'VE TAKEN SUCH LOSSES.
THEY'RE RUBBLING THESE LITTLE
VILLAGES ON THE OUTSIDE.
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS 320 SQUARE
MILES COMPARED WITH ALL OF NEW
YORK CITY IS 300 MILES IN TOTAL.
AGAIN, PRETTY MUCH A STALEMATE
HERE, BUT AGAIN, VERY MUCH A
BLOODY ONE.
LET'S GO DOWN TO THE SOUTH --
>> LET'S LOOK AT THIS CORRIDOR.
WE HAVE RUSSIAN TROOPS PUMMELING
MARIUPOL.
WE'VE HEARD THESE HORRIBLE
STORIES ABOUT CITIZENS BEING
TAKEN OUT INTO RIGS CAMPS OF
SORTS AND THAT CITY BEING
DEVASTATED.
RUSSIA HAS ESTABLISHED A LAND
CORDON BETWEEN THE DONBAS REGION
AND CRIMEA THAT THEY SEIZED IN
2014.
>> YES.
SPANS ALL ACROSS HERE, VERY
IMPORTANT.
MARIUPOL HAS NOT YET FALLEN.
IT IS OUT OF FOOD, FUEL, WATER,
EVERYTHING HEART FOR HEART.
THEY ARE STILL FIGHTING VERY
HARD.
THIS IS THE FIRST PLACE WHERE
THE RUSSIANS ARE HAVING TO GO
BUILDING TO BUILDING, EVERY
SINGLE ROOM HAS TO BE CLEARED IN
THIS KIND OF ENDEAVOR.
THEY'RE FINDING OUT IT'S VERY
SOLDIER INTENSIVE AND IT JUST
EATS AWAY AT THE RESERVES AND
FORCES THAT YOU HAVE.
>> ARE THEY FIGHTING THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY OR THE
UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE OR BOTH?
>> ALL OF THE ABOVE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SAY THE
RUSSIANS HAVE 200,000 AND THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE 100,000.
THE UKRAINIAN HAS 100,000 PLUS
ABOUT EVERY OTHER ADULT IN THE
COUNTED ALL OF WHOM ARE WILLING
TO TAKE UP ARMS OR HELP IN SOME
WAY, EVEN IF IT'S JUST JAM RADIO
SIGNALS.
THEY CALL RUSSIANS IN RUSSIA AND
SAY DO YOU KNOW HOW POORLY THIS
IS GOING FOR YOU.
EVERYONE IS ENGAGED.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY ARE
LITERALLY STARVING.
THIS IS A SIEGE, THAT'S WHAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE DOING HERE.
AGAIN, HOW LONG THEY CAN HOLD
OUT, AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
ONCE, IF THEY DO SURRENDER THESE
FORCES WILL BE FREE TO GO BACK
UP.
IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
UKRAINE MAP OVERALL, THAT WILL
FREE FORCES TO GO UP THIS WAY.
EVENTUALLY YOU CAN SURROUND A
LOT OF UKRAINIAN FORCES IN HERE.
>> THE SIGNIFICANCE OF HAVING
THIS PART RIGHT HERE, WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HERE IS MARIUPOL AND CRIMEA.
CONNECTING CRIMEA WHICH THEY
SEIZED IN 2014 WITH THE DONBAS,
THEY CAN CONSOLIDATE FORCES AND
GO THAT WAY?
>> IT'S THAT ON THE BATTLEFIELD
NOW.
IT'S ALSO YOU HAVE A LINE OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
CRIMEA THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
BRIDGE HERE.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO THE CORRIDOR
HERE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAD
PREVIOUSLY, ALL THEY HAD WAS
THIS TEENY LITTLE BRIDGE WHICH
YOU CAN'T GET EVERYTHING YOU
NEED IF YOU'RE IN THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY ACROSS THIS BRIDGE.
IT'S JUST NOT BIG ENOUGH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHAT'S THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
ODESSA?
>> THAT'S THE LAST BIG PORT,
DIRECTLY ON THE BLACK SEA.
IT'S THE LIFELINE FOR ALL OF
UKRAINE WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT'S
COMING IN.
SO WHAT THEY'VE TRIED TO DO IS
GO HERE, THEY'VE TRIED TO GET
THROUGH MYKOLAIV.
THEY'VE GONE A BIT NORTH TO TRY
TO GET AROUND A RIVER UP HERE.
ULTIMATELY THEY WANT TO INVEST
ODESA IN THE SIEGE.
THERE'S ALSO SHIPPING STANDING
OFFSHORE THAT CAN CONDUCT AN
AMPHIBIOUS LANDING.
SO FAR THAT'S ESSENTIALLY ON
HOLD.
>> THE UKRAINIANS SAY THEY HAVE
KILLED FIVE RUSSIAN GENERALS.
CNN HAS NOT CONFIRMED THAT.
ANOTHER SAYING RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
DON'T APPEAR TO BE PARTICULARLY
MOTIVATED.
I CAN ONLY RECALL ONE AMERICAN
GENERAL BEING KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN IN THE ENTIRE
CONFLICT, AND THAT WAS A
GREEN-ON-BLUE INSIDER ATTACK.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT COMMON --
>> VERY, VERY UNCOMMON.
THIS IS IN THE FIRST THREE
WEEKS.
THESE ARE QUITE SENIOR GENERALS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THEIR COMMAND
AND CONTROL HAS BROKEN DOWN.
THE COMMUNICATIONS HAVE BEEN
JAMMED BY THE UKRAINIANS.
THEY HAD TO GO TO A SINGLE
CHANNEL WHICH IS JAMMABLE.
THAT'S WHAT THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
BEEN DOING THAT.
THEY USE CELL PHONES, UKRAINIANS
BLOCKED THE PREFIX FOR RUSSIA.
THEY TOOK DOWN 3G.
THEY'RE STEALING CELL PHONES
FROM UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
THE COLUMN GETS STOP A AN
IMPATIENT GENERAL GOES FORWARD
TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON, BECAUSE
THERE'S NO INITIATIVE, NO
NON-COMMISSIONED OFFICER CORPS,
NO SENSE OF INITIATIVE AT JUNIOR
LEVELS.
THEY WAIT TO BE TOLD WHAT TO DO.
GETS UP THERE, THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE VERY, VERY GOOD SNIPERS AND
HAVE BEEN PICKING THEM OFF.
AT LEAST FOUR OF THE FIVE HAVE
BEEN CONFIRMED.
I THINK THE FI